despite its age the Nintendo switch is
still going strong we saw games that
appealed to almost every kind of
Nintendo fan from Kirby and the
Forgotten land to Xenoblade Chronicles
3. here are gamespot's 5 best Nintendo
switch games of 2022 and a few honorable
mentions at the end for good measure
before we get going keep in mind that
these games are in no particular order
[Music]
Mario plus Rabbids Kingdom battle was a
bizarre mashup of Nintendo's Mario
ubisoft's Rapids and XCOM like combat it
worked incredibly well despite its
disparate elements but the follow-up
proved itself much more than a mere
iterative sequel Mario plus Rabbids
Sparks of Hope is an improvement in
every meaningful way borrowing just
enough Mario DNA to make a tactical
experience that's unique to the genre
the most obvious difference is the
free-flowing movement allowing you to
run around the battlefield almost like
you would in a traditional Mario
platformer at first this change may seem
superficial but it actually has a
profound impact on gameplay allowing you
to chain your squad's moves one after
another to gain a tactical advantage
over your foes the spark system 2 gives
you an enormous amount of flexibility
over your team composition and strategy
for an experience unlike any other game
in its type Steve Watts wrote in his
review put simply Mario plus rapid
Sparks of Hope is an absolute Delight
this is a combination that shouldn't
work and yet it more than works it
excels
with its hybrid combination of TV and
portable functionality the Nintendo
switch is an ideal venue for deep midi
RPG experiences it doesn't get much more
substantial than Xenoblade Chronicles 3
the latest Epic from monolith soft the
sprawling tale of Warring Nations
tackles themes of sacrifice and
community and while its delivery is
sometimes held back by awkward dialogue
it's enough to care deeply about these
characters once the story hits its
stride equally ambitious is the revised
combat system with 23 classes and
unlockable Master Arts that add an extra
layer of tactical flexibility a
streamlined menu system makes it easy to
manage your mmo-like party and the
result is a system that rewards
experimentation as you play with
different party compositions and
loadouts that level of complexity gives
the experience its longevity as a
reviewer me I'm the reviewer still found
new options in master Arts after 120
hours in one of Nintendo's most
recognizable mascot characters Kirby has
seen his fair share of Platformers along
with more experimental projects on
handheld platforms like the Nintendo DS
even so the little pink puffball still
managed to surprise us this year with
Kirby and the Forgotten land the more
open structured platformer is akin to
the Mario 3D Land and World Games with
diorama-like environments filled with
challenges and obstacles to overcome
this time the world is built to look
more realistic with Real World objects
like traffic cones and even cars for
Kirby to gobble down when he takes on a
particularly large object he transforms
into mouthful mode a clever way to get
new gameplay functionality out of his
classic eating mechanic not only that
but the game also gives us upgradable
versions of many of the classic Kirby
power-ups you don't have to settle for a
little flame ability anymore as you can
become a lava spewing Terror instead it
all culminates in one of the wildest
endings in a Kirby game to date showing
the character still has some tricks up
its sleeve does Kirby have sleeves you
get the idea Pokemon fans got not just
one but two major Pokemon releases this
year and they were each special in their
own way in our opinion though the
standout was Pokemon Legends Arceus a
prequel that takes place in an era
inspired by the Japanese colonization
period the new setting allowed for a
very different take on the Pokemon
formula including a semi-open world
structure full of sprawling environments
to explore rather than the traditional
quest of catching wild Pokemon and
raising to the ranks of Pokemon Master
Arceus put you in the role of a Pokemon
researcher this meant completing
research tasks like defeating a certain
number of Pokemon capturing a certain
type and more the gameplay changed to
facilitate this new take on the Pokemon
Norm with the ability to catch Pokemon
in the Wild by simply tossing a Pokeball
without being seen it makes stealth
traditional Pokemon mechanics and
exploration into a package that was hard
to resist
Wii Sports was a genuine phenomenon that
we don't see in video games the type of
breakout success that inspires
mainstream press attention and finds its
way into the lives of non-traditional
Gamers it only makes sense that Nintendo
would follow up on the switch with its
joy-con functionality acting very
similar to the Wii remote Nintendo
switch Sports is the result a new
package that brings back popular sports
like bowling and Tennis alongside new
events like badminton soccer volleyball
and chimbara like the best social games
switch Sports is best if you can gather
a bunch of friends together to complete
goals knock each other around in an epic
sword duel and more and Nintendo has
made a habit of committing continuing
support to games like this as it
recently added golf to the switch Sports
repertoire it's a great little package
that scratches the itch that made the
Wii Sports such a hit Kurt and Davina
wrote in gamespot's Nintendo switch
Sports review Nintendo switch Sports is
a fantastic multiplayer game that for
the most part invites anyone and
everyone to pick up a controller and
flail their limbs about it has its
issues but they fall away when you have
other people to play with and are
joyously going Toe to Toe in Virtual
Sports as with the original Wii Sports
Nintendo switch Sports finds Beauty and
fun and simplicity and bullying is great
better than real life bowling all right
with that out of the way let's get to
the honorable mentions why don't we
start with the Nintendo exclusives
Nintendo's colorful multiplayer shooter
Splatoon returned in 2022. Splatoon 3
had the same infectious charm as its
predecessors but packed it with a ton of
new and returning content if you're
looking for a vibrant and original take
on the competitive shooter genre then
look no further along with splatting the
competition you'll need to Ink the
playing field in order to win in
addition to the tried and true
multiplayer modes Splatoon 3 also has a
robust single player campaign with some
excellent boss fights and a bite-size
wave defense mode called Salmon Run
let's drop another third entry in this
list and highlight Bayonetta 3.
Bayonetta 3 is platinum games at its
peak this Multiverse hopping character
action game is explosive Adventure chock
full of colorful characters hectic set
pieces and ridiculous weapons including
a train sword or a sword train depending
on how you want to look at it its
visuals do suffer a bit but the Absurd
action and bayonetta's Charming wit more
than makes up for its technical hiccups
Mario has starred in countless party and
sports games but they are almost never
as technically complex and skill testing
as Mario Striker's battle League this
game pits the Mushroom Kingdom All-Stars
against each other in a wild soccer bout
complete with various pieces of
armor-like equipment to Dawn and big
flourishes in the form of unlockable
shots while the content offering is a
bit anemic compared to the best Mario
sports games this is one for the fans
who take their virtual footy seriously
and want to prove it out on the pitch
card shark developed by nerial and
published by devolver digital is an
adventure game that has you cheating
your way to success it takes place in
18th century France and boasts a
colorful art style of course there is a
lot more going on in the story than
meets the eye if this Peaks your
interest I highly recommend checking out
the free demo on the Nintendo switch
storefront a lot has already been said
about near automata at this point many
consider it one of the best games in the
last few years and now you can play it
on switch typically we try to stick to
new releases for our best of the Year
coverage but we were blown away by how
well this port runs on the little hybrid
console if you haven't had the chance to
check out this Platinum Games gem
consider this a sign
there it is our favorite Nintendo switch
games of 2022 and 5 honorable mentions
this should be more than enough to keep
you busy over the holiday season let us
know your favorite switch games in the
comments below and with that we'll see
you next time
[Music]